hey 42 here twitter was started in 2006
by four Internet entrepreneurs and it
took three years to get to one billion
tweets
however today over 1 billion tweets are
sent every week here's some really
interesting things you probably don't
know about Twitter Twitter was actually
created on a playground the founding
team members who at the top of a slide
in the playground in San Francisco when
Jack Dorsey said I've got an idea so
simple you don't even think about it you
just ranked at first glance it may seem
that unlike most websites Twitter is
advertisement 3 but that's not quite
true
Twitter is a business and it does make
money through cleverly disguised
advertisements Twitter has two main
revenue streams firstly Google and Bing
Pei Twitter at Hanson license fee so
that they can include tweets in their
real-time search results and secondly
big brands such as Starbucks Coca Cola
Red Bull and many others pay Twitter for
sponsored tweets which appear in Twitter
search results brands can also pay for
promoted trends which appear amongst the
other naturally trending topics the cost
for a promoted trend in the United
States for one day is $200,000 Twitter
gave the City of Boston a promoted trend
free of charge after the Boston Marathon
bombings in April 2013 the trend was
hashtag 1 Boston but when it comes to
profit twitter is very different from
the likes of Facebook Google and Apple
because Twitter has never made a single
dime of profit in 2014
Twitter made a net worth of 578 million
dollars which can be attributed to its
rapid expansion and excruciating ly high
operating costs
but why our Twitter's operating costs so
high well it has a lot to do with the
fact that 500 million tweets are sent
every day which is an astonishing six
thousand tweets per second all those
messages take an awful lot of processing
power and storage a single day's worth
of Twitter posts would fill a 10 million
page book the person with the most
followers on Twitter is Katy Perry who
has 68 million followers second is
Justin Bieber and third is Barack Obama
the most followed brand on Twitter is
YouTube which has 50 million followers
Twitter wasn't always called Twitter and
it didn't always have a bird as a mascot
when it launched it was called Twitter
without vowels and it looked like Miss
when it was being created friend stalker
was also considered as a potential name
Twitter later added its famous Bluebird
as its mascot who by the way is called
Lauri named after basketball player
Larry Bird Twitter was responsible for
starting the hashtag phenomenon the
first ever use of the hashtag on Twitter
was hashtag BarCamp
posted by an open source software
advocate Chris Messina who thought it
would be a good idea to use the hashtag
to signify a group chris was inspired by
the hashtags heavy use in IRC chat rooms
his now referred to as the hashtag
Godfather we've all heard of a hashtag
but how about a cache tag cache tags
which starts with a dollar sign are used
on Twitter by Wall Street's tweeters
interested in tracking the news around
stocks speaking of news twitter has
become the de-facto source for global
news when something big happens around
the world news of it spreads on twitter
via hashtags faster than any other news
source in the world because of this
twitter is now the prime
resource for the majority of TV news
stations twitter is seen as the home of
super fast and often instantaneous
communication so it may come as a
surprise that between 2008 and 2010 to
help keep the site online Twitter heart
of quote-unquote a guy with a pager
the pager would rotate between for
people who would constantly monitor
Twitter to check if it went offline
these days they're a bit more high-tech
and use automated monitoring systems to
keep the website online twitter has 288
million active monthly users 80 percent
of whom accessed a service through
mobile devices in the early days of
Twitter they were thinking about
introducing a worship button if you
worship someone you would get every
single one of their messages buts the
idea was ditched Twitter CEO Dick
Costolo said that any Twitter employee
can launch any test to 1% of users
without any senior approvals the most
retweeted tweet ever was by Ellen
DeGeneres with her star-studded selfie
tweets into 2014 Oscars it got 3.4
million retweets tweets containing
hashtags received two times the levels
of engagement than those without
hashtags yet only 24% of tweets actually
contain hashtags twitter is on Twitter
but Twitter is also on Facebook and
Facebook is also on twitter twitter is
also on YouTube and YouTube is on
Twitter there is a Twitter account
called every word that has manually
tweeted every single word in the English
dictionary the task took them seven
years to complete there is also a
Twitter account with the username sign
out that has only ever tweeted once but
has 1435 followers
why because apparently some twitter
users think that they can sign out a
twitter by following the account
visiting Guyver twitter comm with an
extra t or twitter.com missing a t we'll
both redirect you to the official
website the average number of followers
of all users on twitter is 208 the FBI
has a dictionary of twitter slang in
order to promote diversity the official
twitter account of sweden is given to a
new random citizen every week to manage
the Library of Congress is archiving
every single tweet sent by an American
citizen because they believe that every
tweet is an important part of the
national narrative of American history
the database of tweets is over 150
terabytes and growing the CIA also reads
up to 5 million tweets a day 44% of
Twitter users have never sent a single
tweet a report found that over 50% of
Justin Bieber's Twitter followers are
fake according to the Vatican you can
reduce the time that you spend in
purgatory by following the Pope on
Twitter unfine illan twitter may not yet
be making a profit but it is worth 30 1
billion dollars and it is the eighth
most visited website on the internet
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you